the only note I got was uh Ronnie seemed
really depressed about his birthday last
week yeah I don't like birthdays anymore
man I understand he yelled at Richard
for wishing him a happy birthday but
Ronnie did go out and celebrate even
though he doesn't like his birthday and
he went to an Italian place and
according to Ronnie uh Pia Zadora often
sings
you got to be pretty old to remember
and here's a bulletin he hung out with
Ronnie for about 10 minutes that night I
remember he likes old goats
oh shut the [ __ ] up man that's now his
friend would you talk to her about no
yeah just you know nothing General [ __ ]
you know hello how are you you know she
looks really good I gotta say I don't
even know how old she is but she looks
She's 16 years old he Isadora was a
woman she married a guy named michulum
Rickles I think his name was I remember
this as soon as I was fascinated and he
bankrolled her career he put out
commercials for her and everything else
and she became famous do you do bunay on
Ice yo you're doing a once or twice
the [ __ ] is wrong with him today
so piazzador is 68 years old Ron so she
looks good now she looked great dude
seriously what was she wearing like a
little like a nice little short dress
and everything yeah it was all done nice
makeup she really looked good and what
does she do at this restaurant she sings
it oh and now she's coming she's very
good friends I'm assuming with the owner
um of the restaurant and it's like this
old school Italian restaurant it's been
there for years
so did you do you know the name of it I
was there you [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you Jesus
Christ you get stoned you forget all
right well happy uh 73 Jesus Ron what
are you doing that's bad man it's hard
it is bad
I was talking to my shrink the other day
and he goes so you had your birthday huh
I got yeah of course
I'm a year older than you this is better
this is bad that's some that's some
shrink yeah can I tell you something a
lot of people are saying 73 is the new
69 so that's fine